rickety antennas fuzzy pictures and
crackly sound TV in the Democratic
Republic of Congo isn't always great but
now the country is ushering in a new era
in the capital Kinshasa the analog TV
signal is being switched off digital is
coming still for most Congolese that's
not something to get excited about posh
flat-screen TV sets are only for the
wealthy wake anissa near the average
salary of a Congolese is somewhere
between 70 and 90 dollars a month how
many years are we supposed to save up
for a new TV won't be any even for those
who do by digital box or new TV there
won't be much to watch a handful of
state-funded channels will be free but
viewers will have to pay for anything
else los tonos upon Fassett meet assumes
on when we made this changeover we
negotiated a clause with the distributor
that our channel would be free that
means that even if someone loses all
their pay channels they won't lose us
Peppa the switchover was supposed to
democratize television in the DRC more
channels mean more choice but in many
African countries neither broadcasters
nor viewers can afford that digital TV
in Kinshasa is an experiment one whose
success remains uncertain